>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> The Library of Congress
has assembled a wealth
of primary sources
for the K-12 educator.
One great place to start is
on the Teachers Page.The staff
of the Library has done much of
the work of finding primary sources
for you, and has created
a number of short cuts
for finding primary
sources without searching.
Most teachers find that the Primary
Source Sets offer easy access
to selected primary sources
that they can use quickly.
A Primary Source Set is a set
of selected primary sources
on a specific topic most of which
are available as easy-to-use PDFs.
Each set also come with historical
background information on its topic
as well as teaching ideas and
tools to guide student analysis.
Primary Sources by State takes
a close-up look at the states
by presenting selected
primary sources for each
of the fifty states, the District of
Columbia and the U.S. territories.
These state sets include primary
sources from different eras
of each state's history, and usually
feature a wide range of formats,
from manuscripts and maps
to films and folk songs.
Another way to find
primary sources is
to use the Today in History feature.
Today in History is available
from the Library's home page.
Today in History features
information and primary sources
on a specific event or events in
history, along with suggestions
for how to search for additional
primary sources on the topic.
In addition, you can
use the archives link
to search all 365 entries for
Today in History or search
for specific topics by keyword.
The Library's experts
are also available
through the Ask a Librarian service
if searching doesn't yield
the primary sources you need.
Look for the Ask a Librarian button
on each Library of
Congress Web page.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.